yesterday I told you about Donald
Trump's disgraceful phone call with
Filipino president Rodrigo Duterte
we went through the transcript yesterday
of this call which was released and in
that call Donald Trump congratulated and
commended Duterte for the Philippines
barbaric extrajudicial killings of
suspected drug users and drug dealers in
a sort of depraved vigilante justice of
sorts Donald Trump saying to president
duterte keep up the good work you were
doing an amazing job we talked about
that yesterday I also mentioned
yesterday that during the call Donald
Trump in one of these efforts to brag
about you know the military power of the
US and the great Intel that he gets
Trump said to duterte hey we've got two
nuclear submarines in Korean waters near
North Korea and I pointed this out
yesterday saying that may not be
something that we actually want the that
we want made public right Donald Trump
saying during this phone call to
president duterte quote we have two
submarines the best in the world we have
two nuclear submarines not that we want
to use them at all I've never seen
anything like like they are but we don't
have to use this but Kim could be crazy
so we will see what happens so what was
the reaction from the Pentagon Pentagon
officials are reportedly in total
disbelief in shock that Donald Trump
casually mentioned this during a phone
call with Filipino president Rodrigo
Duterte
three different Department of Defense
officials spoke to BuzzFeed and they
explained you know people in the
government aren't supposed to talk about
submarines like this sometimes even the
people on the submarines don't know
exactly where we are depending on your
level of security clearance there's no
guarantee that even as someone on one of
these submarines you would know exactly
where you are the movement of these
submarines is something that's crucial
to the success of u.s. naval operation
the national security and Donald Trump
casually says to Rodrigo as he refers to
him it we've got two nukes nuclear subs
right and Korean waters there I think
what's happening is that Donald Trump is
starting to get a bit laxed when it
comes to handling classified information
as a he's been having these briefings
since he won the nomination last summer
yeah and when you have a guy who built a
brand off of grandiosity in braggadocio
I don't think he can help himself even
now that he's president I think he
genuinely can't help himself I think
that I don't know how calculated it is I
think the guy just can't keep his mouth
shut
and these officials that BuzzFeed spoke
to said you know aircraft carriers are
noticeable just from flying over so we
don't really keep secret the location of
aircraft carriers they're easy to spot
airplanes are taking off of them
airplanes are landing on them new
submarines are underwater that's sort of
the point of a submarine that it's not
visible from from the air or from the
surface of the water particularly
nuclear submarines and that's that's
kind of the entire point we don't want
people to detect them and people are
also pointing out astutely I might add
that China is in the process of
developing new submarine detection
technology now that China knows that
we've got two nuclear submarines in
Korean waters this is a great
opportunity for them to test out some of
that new technology so this this is it's
bragging it's irrational it's haphazard
and it's dangerous and it's a risk to
national security I mean what if I say
to you Pat do you feel safer now that
Donald Trump revealed the location of
nuclear subs to Rodrigo Duterte
does that make you feel like oh wow he's
really taking national security
seriously now well he may be revealing
where our nuclear submarines are and he
may be telling the Russians what our
plans are to fight Isis but at least he
you didn't use the wrong laptop yeah
like Hillary Clinton did that's
something yeah and and he didn't have
apparently a private email server oh
okay
Donald Trump I was thinking about
Trump's campaign proclamations that he
is not going to be so stupid as to
reveal any of our military strategy when
it comes to Isis when it comes to North
Korea he's not going to do that it's
becoming clear that he wasn't not
revealing it during the campaign because
of some ability to keep classified
things classified and keep secrets he
genuinely had no plan because as we're
quickly finding out almost as soon as he
finds anything out he's revealing it
yeah I think that was obvious to start
with I mean you would say that he
doesn't want to reveal his plan because
then the whole world would know about it
and he wants to stay one step ahead yeah
I think we knew the whole time he did
actually have a plan